in just a moment I'll speak to the
former business secretary and long time
leading light of the conservative
eurosceptic right Jacob Reese mogg
and a little later we'll hear from the
former Northern Ireland secretary during
the labor government Peter now Lord
mandelson
[Music]
uh with that deal on the Northern
Ireland protocol seemingly within reach
the Prime Minister has a number of
groups to keep on side parties in
Northern Ireland of course and a little
later from here we'll hear from those
but also he has to deal with those in
his own party Who Remain deeply
skeptical of arrangements with the EU
they want the removal of the so-called
trade barrier in the IRSC and want to
ensure that the European court of
justice no longer plays a part in the
protocol
Jacob Brie smallg has long been one of
the leading lights of that wing of the
party the former business secretary
joins me now good morning Mr Reese smog
good morning Miss Phillips
now I know we haven't seen the exact
detail yet but um
can you imagine yourself supporting any
version of a deal that has a role for
the European court of justice
well it depends very much on the
position of the dup that um under the
Good Friday Belfast agreement it set out
that there must be cross-community
consent and this requires a majority in
both communities and and the dup have
set out some very clear tests for
whether or not any agreement works and
it's much more about whether EU law
applies to what goes on in Northern
Ireland over which the people of
Northern Ireland have no say the
European Court the European court is a
consequence of EU law taking effect in
Northern Ireland and that's the matter
that the dup has quite rightly
highlighted
so you could you can see some kind of
arrangement where for example if the EU
wants to make changes in trade
Arrangements it might consult the
Northern Ireland assembly so that the
Democratic deficit about which the dup
is concerned is to some extent remedied
the actual involvement of the EU in uh
policy and legislation is not in and of
itself a red line you're essentially
Outsourcing your judgment to the dup
but no because the dup has set out
um its requirements which I've I've got
here it's seven requirements for a new
one they've got the 720. I want to check
on where you are
I think those seven tests are absolutely
the right tests I think the dup has set
out the right test as to whether a new
agreement is in line with the Good
Friday Belfast agreement which is a
fundamental importance because that's
what's given peace to Northern Ireland
for the last 25 years and that must
underpin everything but also whether uh
Northern Ireland will have the same
Arrangements under article 6 of the act
of Union as the rest of the United
Kingdom which has been the law of this
country uh since the early 19th century
where the laws in Northern Ireland
should be made by the people of Northern
Ireland or of the United Kingdom Ron
imposed upon them by the European Union
and that's what the ecj becomes a
consequence of now I think the dep's
position is extremely reasonable that's
why I'm supporting it
to some people this will seem a little
bit puzzling
if the elected government in Westminster
which is the highest Democratic uh
expression if I can put it that way of
the Union uh decides it likes the deal
it will accept it uh it might be
possible that one party or another or
some members of your own political party
don't fancy it very much but
if you see if you basically this is
about sovereignty if Westminster decide
this is the way to go presumably you'll
you're going to say to dup you've got to
swallow it
no that misunderstands The Good Friday
agreement that
there that has led to peace as I said
for 25 years that means you need
cross-community consent and there was a
very clear promise that there would be
no change to the Constitutional
arrangement of Northern Ireland without
that cross-community consent and the
Northern Ireland protocol itself says
that it is subsidiary to the Good Friday
agreement so that's really very
important and this I think Alters the
tone of the question that you're asking
of course
forgive me we seem to be losing a little
bit of
carry on do carry on
in Northern Ireland because of the
history there is a very particular way
in which changes may be made to the
arrangements there and those have to be
followed and that's one of the seven
tests set out by the dup
e but you you understand my point here
don't you that
in the end uh in our democracy
ultimately whatever an agreement that
was made in uh 25 years ago may may or
may not say whatever any individual
party thinks if Westminster decide that
is
surely the outcome of the sovereignty
for which you have argued so
vociferously vociferous lymph I may say
so eloquently for the last six years
Westminster decides
Friday agreement which is
um co-gu guaranteed by the British
government
so you would be expecting his Majesty's
government to tear up something he had
already agreed to so of course those
it feels like but it has to legislate
within a political context of agreements
it's already made and an agreement that
is fundamental to peace seems to me to
be that the highest order of magnitude
and a government would not want to
override that Westminster would not want
to override that without going through
the proper processes and that requires
the support of the dup all right before
we move on absolutely fundamental before
we move on though I want to talk to you
about the economy but just very quickly
um
you will probably be aware that the
former prime minister Boris Johnson has
had something to say about all of this
this morning
what's he up to
We are continuing or whether we've
concluded
or if we've lost signal
do carry on I think I can still hear you
Mr E smog um I was asking you what do
you think that the former prime minister
Boris Johnson is up to it is not usual
for a former leader to intervene in this
way at such a delicate moment
yeah I okay I regret to say we may have
to give up to uh on Mr Reese Smog on uh
as uh Alan Partridge used to say
on that bombshell